so we're gonna play some what's more
likely and the first category involves
this game between two teams who are
teetering on the brink as it relates to
whether or not they're going to have a
chance to make it to the postseason so
what's more likely kirk cousins doesn't
throw an interception against the texans
or texans quarterback desean watson is
sacked only once chris i think i'm gonna
go with this is a tough one because i i
don't really believe in either one but i
think if i'm gonna pick one i'll go with
kirk cousins doesn't throw an
interception just because the texans
defense is not good i mean there's no
other way to say it really they can't
really stop the run all that well
they're not great in the secondary they
make mistakes every week i mean we saw
last week pittsburgh threw
big ben through a shallow cross and
there was nobody there on the field
i believe to defend him if i'm
remembering that play the correct way
but
i think i'll take that just because
right now the texans are a little
offensively challenged too and i think
deshawn wants it in they're not pass
protecting great and he's going to
scramble around and try to make his
plays that way and that's going to lead
to a few more sacks i think this is a
game for cousins that he might not have
to take a number of chances and might
not get the hell beat out of him to
where he has to throw balls while he's
getting crushed or killed every you know
every other drop back pass
i think it's more likely that desean
watson is sacked only once because
consider look the vikings lost their
wednesday i mean
we've been talking so much about the
the
potential unfairness of the titans not
being fully prepared for the steelers
you're right we haven't really no uh
focused on the idea that the vikings who
were just the bystanders in all this
they just had the short straw of playing
the team that had the outbreak
they don't get to come back to work
until today they're already behind
and that may lead to them pressing a
little bit more the quarterback trying
to do more to make things happen the
defense of the texans being better
prepared to face an offense that hasn't
had the time to properly plan and and
prepare from an execution standpoint on
how to beat it so i i think it's more
likely that cousins throws an
interception so based on our two choices
it's more likely that deshaun watson is
sacked only where where are we at with
danielle hunter like in his health is he
getting close to here anytime soon
being bad he's still on yeah injured
reserve he hasn't been activated yeah
okay so we're not hearing anything yet
there too okay all right go ahead the
window opened as of yesterday for him to
come back he didn't come back i guess in
theory he could still come back but see
until he comes back they don't have to
tell us what the injury is yeah it was
the perfect timing by the vikings they
they
they kicked the can for all of training
camp and just said it's a tweak it's a
tweak it's a tweak and then on the day
that the first injury report would have
come out in advance of week one he got
placed on ir so now he's in a position
where he can come back but he isn't back
yet all right all right next topic the
patriots two and one at the chiefs
three and oh by the way the patriots
seven point underdogs for only the third
time in the last is that right seven
points years wow yes wow we're gonna be
doing the pix podcast by the way later
this morning it i can tell that chris is
already fully prepared not for the
spreads you know i just picked the games
first i'm not i don't i haven't left the
spreads yet
what's more likely in this game between
the patriots and the chiefs the chiefs
hold the patriots to under 125 rushing
yards or
patrick mahomes throws an interception
man okay so here's one little
interesting angle that does jump out to
me about this chiefs patriots football
game the fact that the chiefs got to
play the baltimore ravens last week and
see that offense right
i do think that's going to help them out
for the new england attack i i do you
know because again not that it's exactly
the same
but in theory there's a lot of
similarities there quarterbacks in the
shotgun quarterback can run there's
moving parts everywhere oh is it going
this way is it going that way oh wow
they're double pulling guards and the
quarterbacks keeping it in the running
so
that to me is going to help kansas city
out
i think and what kansas city did to
baltimore last week is they called their
bluff early in the game especially they
called their bluff they just said we're
going to get in your face and play
man-to-man and there's going to be nine
guys right at the line of scrimmage
and do you have the guts to start the
game off throwing balls with lamar
jackson and trying to beat us with the
pass game and baltimore didn't and then
of course they got they fell behind so i
have a feeling that same situation is
going to prevent it present itself once
again so i'm going to go
with
patrick mahomes
throws an int i am i'm going to go with
it not that i think it's going to be a
game losing int or anything like that
but i think he'll be aggressive against
this patriots secondary
they're good they might make one play
and that's where i'll give him to them
like i think he throws a game where he
throws three maybe four touchdowns and
just like one interception something
like that
okay i'm confused are you saying the
chiefs are or aren't going to hold the
patriots under 125 russians i think they
i think they are i guess i that's what
i'm saying yes i am i'm thinking well
then that's your choice then that's more
likely you know what you're right that's
that's my you're right you're right i
don't know what i was thinking there i i
don't i don't either i don't either i i
guess i was confused in my brain about
which way i was going there so yes i'm
going with the ch i'd rather go
with the the chiefs defense i mean i
mean my home's throwing interception
because i believe the chief's defense
will be prepared to stop that great
running game of the patriots there we go
so
all right this is quickly becoming who's
on first the choices are this the chiefs
hold the patriots under 185 yards
rushing or patrick holmes throws an
interception i'm going
i'm gonna go then with the chiefs
holding the patriots under 125 to choose
it thank you i got it right final answer
need a lifeline are you sure i do badly
look okay so so to set up your your
point yeah the chiefs are going to do
the same thing
to the patriots that they did to the
ravens right do you believe that the
patriots will be able to throw the ball
more effectively
and be more willing to throw the ball
than the ravens were yes yes and yes and
that's why i i was thinking of that too
and that's where i was getting all
myself confused there because we don't
know these things right so i just want
to tell people on tv and everything we
see i'm just seeing this little element
right now i'm going with it on the fly
here i didn't get to like prepare for
this so but yes my thought there is that
they're gonna get in the face of these
these patriot wide receivers they're
gonna call the bluff on yes
you're gonna have to drop back and pass
to beat us and we think our cover guys
are pretty good and your receivers are
still questionable at this point i think
they will but i think the patriots and
cam newton are they're a better passing
team to me than the baltimore ravens i
would rather trust them in that
situation than i would uh baltimore as
far as attacking through the air against
that kansas city defense
and while we're in the vicinity of the
fourth wall let's go ahead and kick it
down what chris is saying is we just
show up and we just sit down and we our
prep is what we carry around in our
brains the accumulation of everything we
do all day every day so it's kind of
like remember that show whose line is it
anyway yeah that's kind of this isn't
scripted i mean we have a general idea
of what the show is going to be about
right but we we really don't plan
anything out we just sit down and we
look at what the next segment is and we
kind of come up with things on the fly
and sometimes it works
and sometimes you can talk yourself
because music sometimes it doesn't work
all right um
which one i i think
clearly i agree i agree with you and i
think that that this is going to be cam
newton's ultimate test as the
quarterback of the new england patriots
the you know patrick holmes and and cam
newton have never crossed paths before
the last time the panthers and the and
the chiefs played
was in 2016 when patrick mahomes was a
texas tech so this is you know for as
compelling as monday night was maybe
this one will be even better because
maybe cam newton is better suited to
cross swords with patrick mahomes to not
say hey this is superman superman's not
going to say that the chiefs are his
kryptonite this is a superman who's
impervious to kryptonite right except
when he gets injured other than that but
but i i think that it's going to be a
very compelling contrast and
and i think that cam newton is going to
be keenly aware that
lamar jackson was the mvp last year
and in the aftermath of the game sunday
win or lose yeah how cam newton fares
against that defense that just shut down
lamar jackson that just held him under
97 yards that just left him
flustered and frustrated in the fourth
quarter
that if cam newton can perform under
those circumstances even if they fall
short like they did against the seahawks
it reflects very well
on cam newton and and he's he's going to
know that and i think the coaches are
going to know that to push his buttons
and get him ready so i agree with you
fewer than 125 yards rushing but maybe a
passing game from cam like the one we
saw week two against
exactly that's what i think and i think
you know again with kansas city as we've
talked about so many times over the last
two years too
i would just have a hard time thinking
they're going to want to die a slow
death like the raiders did last week
where you're just going to let the
patriots hold the ball the whole second
half and just smash it down your face
for six yards and seven yards at a time
right i mean we know that's a disservice
to the chiefs their best thing about
their team is the guy that playing
quarterback and the receivers around him
and what they do there so they don't
want to be on the sidelines for you know
40 minutes of this game so i do that's
where i really look at it and i think
spags will force the issue to go you're
gonna have to beat us with the pass
today we like our corners and we're not
sure how good your receivers are quite
yet and i and ultimately i think the
pats will have some success too because
i think cam newton's a better thrower
than lamar jackson i think he'll stand
in there and be more comfortable within
the pocket and i think josh mcdaniels
has more creative ways to get people
open than i do greg roman and just
especially the drop back pass game
and bill belichick understands
the chiefs are going to score their
points they're going on that 18-2 run at
some point during the game you've got to
score points when you can you got to
take touchdowns over field goals you've
got to have not necessarily sustained
methodical drives to keep patrick
mahomes on the sidelines although that
helps but you've just got to score your
points because they're going to score
their points whether they have limited
opportunities maximum opportunities
they're still going to score their
points all right the bills who scored 35
points on sunday against the rams go to
las vegas for the second game ever at
allegiant stadium what's more likely
josh allen throws for 300 plus passing
yards or derek carr throws an
interception carr one of the handful of
quarterbacks who's yet to throw an
interception this year no i know and
that's why i'm gonna go with josh allen
throws for 300 yards for two reasons one
um
first off the raiders are aggressive in
the second year the raiders got some
pretty good cover guys they do and then
they they're not bad there now they lost
their rookie first-rounder arnette to i
think the hand injury right so he won't
be able to play but because they're kind
of had that confidence in their corners
and everything like that do i don't know
if that's a good thing this week not
against this team not against this guy
right now who's playing like other than
wilson and mahomes the third best
quarterback in the sport or at least in
that conversation with rogers i mean
he's on fire and then the weapons we
know are legit it's hard to match up
with them right now so i am going to go
300 yards because first off i don't
think derek carr is gonna take a lot of
chances the bills don't have a great
pass rush they play a lot of zone
coverage as we talked about yesterday so
they don't make you always throw the
ball into really really tight windows
that way
and i think the raiders are gonna be
able to run the ball on buffalo as we
saw the rams do to buffalo last week so
i think because of that i just can't
imagine carr taking many chances i'm
gonna go with allen and what we've seen
the first three weeks was just them
bombing it away
yeah i agree with you there as well uh
and i think really
both have a chance of happening but the
buffalo defense as we've talked isn't
isn't isn't at as high level no as it
was in recent years but josh allen is at
an incredibly high level and he's just
going to continue to do it and just
overpower that raiders defense all right
colts two and one at bears three and oh
what's more likely
nick foles solidifies his starting spot
or we're talking about mitchell trubisky
in wistful terms next week this is uh to
me this is one of the under the radar
best games of the weekend i i really do
think this i mean this is a colts team
that i look at and still go damn they
should be 3-0 and they look good when i
watch them like there's some parts of
their team
they will they will absolutely maul you
up front on both sides of the ball so
build a wall yeah they built the wall
two walls and they have the ability and
they built somebody else to break other
people's walls i mean so it's it's they
got it all going um but i do think
nonetheless it'll be nick foles
solidifies the starting spot i have no
doubt about that i really don't
you know
again the thing that i think i look at
is just such a better pure passer
better decision maker i think the
offense was more aggressive as soon as
he came in the game and that speaks to
me in like football world that the coach
trusts this guy more so he's more
willing to call aggressive plays and i
think foles will show that he is
certainly better than mitch trubisky uh
this could be an interesting game though
this is one of those i'm still not sure
who i'm gonna pick game yeah i think win
or lose uh falls as the guy for a while
i don't think the bears fans who have
been fretting about trubisky for the
last two years are suddenly going to
abandon nick foles after one game
because he's already come in and built
up some equity with the come from behind
win over the falcons so look even the
most ardent bears fan is going to accept
the fact that three in one is a hell of
a start to the season and the cults are
pretty damn good and they have to
refocus quickly on tom brady coming to
town so it's not like you have a normal
week in the aftermath of this game to
sit around and say who should the
quarterback be they got to get right
back to it they've got two challenging
games four days apart
and and that's that that is both
fascinating and terrifying to think
that when the bears wake up sunday
morning
they are four days away four days away
yeah from being five and oh
three and two or four and one crazy and
you get all and then those those are
gonna be very impactful games on the
final standings on on
how well they have a shot at getting to
the postseason as i said earlier this
week if they start 4-0 they just go 500
the rest of the way and they're 10-6
that's what those early season wins mean
so we'll see what they can do yeah
browns 2-1
cowboys and two what's more likely dak
prescott throws for 350 or more passing
yards or nick chubb the browns top
running back rushes for 100 yards or
more and two touchdowns what's more
likely
this one's easy
it's easy for you
well yeah i i'm going to go with nick
chubb i'm going to go with that i mean
maybe it's not maybe yeah well it it i
mean 350 yards is a lot of yards it
really is and you know you're i mean
i want you're right i looked at both of
these and went like i mean i could
easily see dak prescott going for 350
yards against this cleveland brown
secondary that has not been all that
impressive yet and certainly
hasn't had a play i'm just going through
my brain here real quick
an offense like this with this passing
attack but i think if i'm going to take
one or the other i'm going to go with
nick chubb
the cowboys have not stopped the run all
that well here through the first few
weeks of the season so that concerns me
and nick chubb to me is you know we talk
about he's special and there and we've
talked about their offensive line when
they run the ball they are special
they moved washington out of the way a
bunch of times last week and washington
nobody's been moving him out of the way
so far so
i'm gonna go with that i could certainly
see both happening there's no doubt but
i think cleveland's got to do this they
got to be going in this game a little
going we can't get in a shootout with
them i don't think we can
we need to run the ball and keep that
dallas offense off the field a little
bit i think they'll be a little
cognizant of that and the and want to
run the ball
but don't you think they're frothing at
the mouth a little bit for the
opportunity to go against a secondary
that that got shredded by russell wilson
last week that's the challenge i know
you know we say run the ball run the
ball run the ball and last week obj
waves the white flag and says i'm not
going to have a huge year statistically
and then the coach kevin stefanski says
not so fast every game is going to be
different i mean this would be the
ultimate rope-a-dope type of a thing
where
we all think including the cowboys
they're going to run the ball run the
ball run the ball maybe this is a
confidence builder game for the passing
game which helps set up more of a pick
your poison type of of a situation if
you can improve that's that's the ideal
situation
for the cleveland browns to not have
this one-dimensional attack that hinges
on the run and then you come up against
a team that stops it you can't do
anything this is a great
almost like pre-season simulation type
game where you've got an opportunity to
work your passing game out a little bit
more and maybe you try to do it i don't
know
that makes me even more confident it's
going to be dak prescott with 350 or
more passing yards i haven't seen
anything yet
with the browns just tell me they can
get in the shootout and you could trust
them to go do that i i just i don't know
if they were there yet
you know
again washington i know they did that to
the bengals and made some plays too but
it wasn't like it was wide open like
we're coming out and shooting out they
started the game throwing a few balls to
be aggressive but what did they go back
to the run game and nick chubb and
that's kind of how they solidified that
game plus
you know
again baker mayfield was not like i know
they won last week and he threw two
touchdowns it was not like a great game
by their passing offense by any stretch
of the imagination
you know washington had cleveland on the
ropes a little bit and haskins made some
dumb plays that gave cleveland short
fields and it really changed the game
that way so i guess yeah i just i think
they got to rely on that run game i
could see this definitely being
something that both of these happen
though there's no doubt
you know it's funny we try to talk about
as many teams as we can but i'm reminded
that we must not be talking about
cincinnati enough because i hadn't heard
you say bangles
in a while been a while don't worry i
when i say it i always get somebody on
twitter that's like it's not an 80s band
they're a cat in cincinnati
all right ravens and washington getting
together this weekend ravens two and one
coming off of that loss to the chiefs
what's more likely lamar jackson bounces
back or washington replicates the
chief's blueprint defensively against
baltimore yeah i well i think washington
will be a pain in the butt for baltimore
here for a little while i really do yeah
the defense is too damn good i mean when
you really look at them man i mean this
secondary plays well too to where
i'm gonna go with lamar
jackson bounces back
but it's not necessarily because i think
it's gonna be like
it's gonna start the game out we're
gonna be like oh he's good it's all good
man they're going up and down the field
look at him he threw for 200 yards in
the first half of the game i don't think
it'll be like that i think it'll have to
be more of like it might be ugly first
but their defense in baltimore really
wears down washington's offense to where
then the defense of washington is just
on the field too much and just can't
constantly keep pace with baltimore and
like a dam they break and that's it so i
think it's more likely that he bounces
back but it won't be like easy and
unbelievable statistics to where we're
just blown away i don't think that
happens
there's a fascinating psychological
experiment that's going on in baltimore
now because remember after the first
game i talked to john harbaugh how do
you get your guys to forget about last
season he said we're not forgetting
about last season we're trying to live
up to that standard well you get your
bubble burst after two games that are
making you feel pretty good about
yourselves you encounter your kryptonite
early in the season and the ravens put
on social media yesterday a video that's
a montage of all the guys on the
sidelines saying
it's just one game we got to refocus
it's just one you know
this one's a dangerous game for me
because on a short week
after getting your butts kicked yeah
after being reminded that for as good as
you think you are against everyone else
there's an impediment to what you're
trying to ultimately become
the it's gonna take everything they can
to forget about monday night and move on
and and uh and be the team that they're
capable of being so i have concerns
about this one i don't know that he's
gonna bounce back
um i don't maybe it's just going to be a
grinded out game where they win it you
know maybe maybe he gets shut down to a
certain extent i i think they what they
need to do is try to come out and just
reestablish themselves
methodically with the running game the
way the chiefs are the the browns did
excuse me against washington yeah uh i
think that's their best chance that this
is a confidence rebuilder type of a game
and they need to be careful that they
don't press too much
that that they don't try too hard
that they don't have too much urgency if
they just get back to their basics the
basics work yeah against most teams
right get back to the basics rebuild
your confidence so i i've kind of talked
my way through the maze yeah i think you
will have a bounce back game because i
think the game plan needs to be
run the ball run the ball run the ball
and only pass it sparingly or if they
put everybody up at the line of
scrimmage that's where like i think it
could be interesting though you know i
do because
you know one we saw a little regression
last week with lamar jackson there's no
doubt i mean he made a few throws in
that game where
you know i was even talking to my father
about this yesterday and we were just
like damn i thought he was kind of
past that that we weren't going to see
throws that kind of come out of his hand
funny and do that so that bothered me a
little and the other thing i'll say too
mike
i just wouldn't be shocked if the the
chiefs kind of threw out the blueprint
last week to where teams maybe play
baltimore like this early in the game
and go okay
here it is
you're going to have to throw it early
to beat us we're not going to let the
run game just gash us down the field and
do all that i i just wonder if we're
going to see teams start to kind of get
more gutsy along that to go you can't
stop everything in baltimore because
they're talented and they're good so
let's just stop the things they're best
at and most dangerous at and see if they
can beat us with their weakest link and
that's still their drop back pass game
and
i think we could see that here going
forward in washington playing real
aggressive early kind of calling their
bluff that way well and look what's the
trend that's come to light in the
aftermath of the monday night game if
the ravens are behind at halftime they
can't come back so
go all in early take your chances early
and if you get lucky and you build a
lead against the ravens maybe
maybe at some level they just i don't
want to say they check out but but
they just they're not built to come from
behind yeah so
force the issue early
that's the way to seize the momentum and
then hold on late again given the record
of lamar jackson's ravens against
everyone other than the chiefs right it
would be hard to think the ravens aren't
going to pull this off but you're right
they've the chiefs have maybe
maybe begun the process of cracking a
code here right the ravens are going to
have to work hard to scramble yeah
they're going to have to come up with
some other way if if this is what
ultimately happens to them week in and
week out one more thing i just want to
bring up because you brought up like the
psychosis element and everything like
that too and like what's going on there
in baltimore and of course lamar
jackson's being questioned a little bit
in the past game too and just i also
find it very
you know intriguing of how complementary
the ravens have been towards patrick
mahomes i mean over the last
before the game and after the game
whether it was wink martindale going a
billion dollars is still not enough for
this quarterback and then i know guys on
the team made similar comments on that
on the tuesday pressers or maybe it was
yesterday's press or whatever basically
saying that too
i would think that kind of rubs lamar
the wrong way that he's now become the
questionable guy and how his own team is
talking about the greatest thing since
sliced bread patrick mahomes to wear i
would think he's a very highly motivated
person this week and we'll see what that
does in this game
yeah we'll see if it wakes something up
or if it causes him to try to do too
much like we see carson wentz try to do
too much and that leads to the sunday
night game last one real quickly eagles
at the 49ers what's more likely carson
wentz throws no interceptions or nick
mullins throws two or more touchdown
passes against the philly defense i'm
going to go with nick mullen stores two
or plus td passes i mean i i can't you
can't go with carson wentz throwing zero
interceptions i mean i don't is that
possible right now i mean he'll probably
have seven guys on his back at one point
and try to throw the ball 40 yards down
the field that's what he does
it's like you know i really like him and
want to root for him because i see
really high end talent but that that
crap pisses me off i can't lie because i
like him and i want i'm just like come
on man like stop some of this stupid
crap and the other thing i look at is
a few weeks ago when the rams played the
eagles the rams just absolutely exposed
the eagles especially in the first half
and jim schwartz a little and then
schwartz kind of adjusted and went to
man-to-man and stopped being so confused
by everything going every which
direction with the rams and all that and
they played a little bit better in the
second half but i think that could be a
thing that happens this week where he's
so worried about the shanahan run game
that they get into some man-to-man
situations maybe a little too much and
if you do that shanahan will have
something for you to where all of a
sudden yeah you think you're stopping
the run and you go whoa george kittle's
running down the field wide open or they
picked one of our guys and brandon iuk
has got nobody in the screen around him
so i'll go with mullins and throw in the
two tds
yeah i agree with you as well you know
that there is a
i think a dynamic the eagles where
everybody needs to calm down and they're
having a hard time
calming down part of it is the pressure
from the fans part of it is just within
the organization it feels like there's
so much stress it does in the eagles
maybe winning that super bowl was a
curse i don't know but everybody seems
on edge
everybody seems nervous everybody seems
like they're trying to do too much and
you know i think we talked about this
earlier in the week like you fall behind
in the first half that's fine it's okay
the game's not over i mean the packers
were down 14 to three against the lions
they didn't freak out ended up blowing
them off the field right right no i know
i might i think it's a very fair point
and i think like you said even the fans
and the media i feel like ever since
they've won the super bowl they expect
super bowl every year now super bowl why
we're super bowl super bowl super bowl
super bowl it's not that easy it's not
and they've been to the playoffs every
freaking year since then
and yeah they've hit some hiccups here
and life has gotten hard i mean they
don't help out carson wentz either i
mean we know that as much as we want to
blame and he needs to be better at
managing the football game damn there is
nobody on that offense that is scary or
nothing systematically i look at right
now to go whoa they do this really good
and it's hard for teams to figure out
this scheme the way they do it just a
lot of question marks with with
philadelphia right now and offensively
challenge against that 49ers defense i
know it's still banged up defense but
it's still a good one and they can still
rush the passer and without weapons it's
just gonna it's gonna lead him to force
a ball and throw an interception
yeah and you know i i said this
yesterday on our football pod in america
eagles fans chill
you have a fairly new lombardi trophy
and there are plenty of fans out there
that would love to just have that one in
the lobby not two not six
not ten
one would be fine the bills would love
to have one the bengals would love to
have one the browns would love to just
get to a super bowl for crying out loud
the titans the jaguars the texans
the chargers
that's just the afc you're on a roll the
teams that don't have super bowls but
i'm just saying yeah just be happy
that you you've got your super bowl
don't expect it every single year and
you're in the nfc least and you're never
dead in the nfc some sort of a drug i
don't know that you know
there are plenty of fan bases out there
that would love to have that problem of
having to adjust their reality to it i
know where you're going to to the fact
that there's a super bowl trophy in the
lobby how do we how do we go forward now
that we've actually finally made it to
the top of the mountain
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports